cooperation and containment that's what
the us president is said to want from
his chinese opposite number biden and xi
have been talking on the phone for the
first time since march after russia
invaded ukraine beijing has failed to
denounce moscow's war instead it's
threatened taiwan with invasion china
considers it part of its territory the
island governs itself democratically
biden has offered to come to its defense
if she tries reuniting taiwan with the
mainland u.s house speaker nancy pelosi
is said to be planning a visit to the
island beijing has warned of
consequences if such a high-profile
visit takes place it's important for us
to show support
mishanna kufner is following the story
for us from washington
it sounds easy just picking up the phone
but i don't think it's going to be that
easy for both leaders is it
well but they certainly have a lot to
talk about but these are testing times
the leadership of both joe biden here
facing economic data that's pointing
further and further towards a potential
recession here and xi jinping who in
october or november will have to face a
people's assembly there is no viable
democracy in china yet at the same time
that is an event where xi jinping could
see himself either strengthened or
weakened so both leaders need to ooze
power coming out of this telephone
conversation we're still waiting any
minute now for an advisory on what could
have been discussed because usually the
white house sends a readout but that
hasn't arrived yet so they may well
still be talking
biden's been especially unpopular with
beijing though hasn't he with
his his calls for her promises to defend
taiwan
yes he answered yes when he was asked
whether he would defend taiwan
potentially militarily the united states
have committed themselves to military
support also legally at the same time
they don't recognize taiwan as an
independent state and do pursue
something
called one china policy as well so uh
where does that leave both sides well in
a potential standoff as we are observing
china um exercising more and more power
and demonstrating more power in the
south china sea this all already came to
a head in the mid 90s which in the end
saw china actually sending rockets into
the sea
off the shores of taiwan now we're
nowhere near that but that visit of
nancy pelosi the speaker of the house
who can completely independently take
decisions of the president although she
is from the same party that could well
escalate tensions and if she backed down
and decided not to go that could portray
the united states as weakened so a very
difficult diplomatic territory both
between the two countries but also
amongst the democrats here who do face
midterm elections this fall and mikhail
i stress the word containment earlier
the u.s has said that china needs to be
contained where does that fit into this
conversation
well let's look at the economics it's it
is yes china trying to expand its power
in the south china sea and further
afield through its belt and road policy
um the us leading an initiative to
oppose that
in investment initiative in
within the g20 but also just having
passed a bill to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars into chip production
here in the us and that is so vital
because supply lines recently have not
just been hampered
by the pandemic but particularly by chip
production not keeping up and the main
exporter of those chips is indeed taiwan
and that's why it makes it a jewel in
the crown when it comes to international
economic power you heard it from
michelle now our correspondent in
washington thank you very much
and let's bring in ian chong an
associate professor at the national
university of singapore who focuses on
chinese foreign policy thanks for being
on the show today what do you expect
from this call between biden and she
honestly uh i expect quite a lot of
bluster and positioning but i really do
not expect any resolution to the
differences because the
issues at hand are very much intertwined
with domestic issues in both china the
prc and also the us so i don't think
leaders on the leaders on either side
have very much room for new maneuver
well uh with this crucial election
coming up for xi jinping i i bet there's
a lot of uh
well i wouldn't say acting but
a lot of playing to uh to the public
going on uh especially this anger over
nancy pelosi's proposed visit to taiwan
wouldn't you say
so um on the xi side it's not that he's
going for election i think it's pretty
clear he has his third term it's about
him being able to uh push his agenda
through being able to put his key allies
into important positions and uh the way
that she has positioned himself as the
leader of china is one that you know
focuses a lot on ethno-nationalism on uh
bringing up china's sort of national
sentiment uh sometimes in rather sort of
ethnic terms and
that can come out as pretty strident so
what that creates is a dynamic in the
prc where everyone has an incentive to
look strong no one has an incentive to
look weak uh least of all she so
i think uh there's going to be a lot of
forcefulness coming from xi and
certainly we see that on his rhetoric on
taiwan there's this new thing that he's
putting forward about how the taiwan
strait isn't international waters where
previously the the prc had not raised uh
these sorts of concerns so there's that
moving of the needle i think to position
she in a stronger position uh that
creates more friction not only with
taiwan but the u.s and u.s allies
talking about looking strong uh taiwan's
holding its biggest ever military drill
right now uh are the concerns of an
invasion real
so taiwan has had to deal with the
potential of her invasion for a really
long time um in the in the
late 90s early 2000s there was a view
that perhaps the economics would be more
important that certainly hasn't played
out so with the invasion of ukraine by
russia i think many people in town start
realizing that war could be quite real
so there's a lot more seriousness put
into the
current hang 138
exercise but it's not just the military
side there's a big civil defense element
that has seen far more uh involvement
from the public than was in the past so
this uh on taiwan's side there's
preparedness but i think they're also
trying to send china a signal that any
attempted invasion will be costly
lastly what sort of a chance of
of us getting any sort of cooperation
from these two leaders when when both
sides would like to see the other
contained
well i think for the us they've been
trying to talk about constrainment not
so much about containment the chinese
side has talked about containment
has accused the us of trying to contain
them now there is a lot to cooperate
over the the economy uh the continuing
pandemic
climate change but unfortunately i think
the politics on the two sides and the
mutual suspicions are so deep and also
the need for china to push this
nationalist narrative is so ingrained
that i think they that sort of very
useful and reasonable cooperation might
unfortunately have to be forgone
ian chong from the national university
of singapore thank you very much for
getting your take on this
thank you
let's turn to an expert on china and its
interactions with taiwan mariko ulbac
from the german marshall front think
tank
if you look at the drills there in
taiwan in moscow's invasion on ukraine
is it now really more likely that she
will take a page out of putin's book and
move on taiwan
i think it's definitely what's
definitely the case is that everybody is
watching very closely what's happening
in ukraine whether that is the chinese
side or the taiwanese side or the u.s
side that doesn't mean that there is you
know an imminent chinese invasion of
taiwan but everybody is studying what's
happening in ukraine and it's kind of
adjusting their plans accordingly and i
think they're right to take it seriously
now biden and shia are talking on the
phone today uh does taiwan need to be a
a topic there
i think taiwan will inevitably be a
topic i mean this phone call was set up
a while ago so i think initially the
plan was to talk you know about various
issues ukraine economy tariffs and those
things are still going to come up what
but with um nancy pelosi's planned visit
to taiwan and and the tensions around
that i would be very surprised if xi
jinping and joe biden decided to ignore
that topic altogether
now we've touched upon the topic earlier
what might china have learned from the
international reaction to the invasion
of ukraine
um i think on the one hand they've
definitely
learned that the costs may be higher
than they expected i do think that the
chinese side was taken aback
by the response um in europe and the
united states that there was a fairly or
a much more resolute response than they
had expected so i do think that does ca
that's something they're taking into
account um and i think this is also why
it's important to signal strongly
towards
china that the economic repercussions of
any any military steps in taiwan would
be quite severe
now
who has the upper hand at the moment in
this rather complicated relationship
sheobad
um i mean this is like a really hard
question to say i don't think it's
necessarily a question of of an upper
hand or not they both
have issues to deal with they both have
severe constraints and um i i do hope
that both sides still have some interest
in not letting it come to the worst um
so this is not an easy issue where you
could say x or
x or y has the upper hand
but i call back there from the german
martial fund think tank thank you very
much
thanks for having me